okay so i'll say straight away that the
batman is one of the best comic book
movies i've ever seen one for you easter
egg heads it's filled with hidden
details and an ending that's bound to
put a smile on that face throughout this
video we're going to be giving a full
breakdown of the film and talking about
where things could be heading in the
future because of this there's going to
be major spoilers so if you haven't had
a chance to check it out then you better
christian bale on the breakdown as i
don't want to be robbing you of your
first experience seeing the film if you
enjoyed the video then make sure you hit
the thumbs up button and also don't
forget to subscribe for puns that aren't
half bad like harvey dent without the
way thanks for clicking this now let's
get into the batman the hell are you
supposed to be
i'm vengeance now the first major thing
i want to talk about in the video is
very much where we leave batman at the
end of the film throughout the movie he
refers to himself as vengeance and he's
very much the embodiment of revenge
however come the end of this he finally
leans more into being the batman and he
leaves the vengeful side of his
personality behind this comes after a
riddle lagoon says that they're
vengeance too and he realizes the impact
that he's had throughout the movie he
constantly sees the x-men's son and he
saves him at several points somewhat
saving himself and the boy that saw his
parents die as a kid mei's son did this
too and thus he decides to drop the
vengeance persona to become the batman
we'll talk about how you might adopt the
bruce wayne playboy persona later on but
i think this character rock is very
important to bear in mind as though this
is the air 2 story it is in many ways an
origin for the new matt reeves take
swing
i'm sorry
the next thing i want to touch upon is
where we leave things off at the end of
the movie after batman foils riddler's
plans we catch him in arkham alongside a
mysterious inmate played by barry keown
the character's face is extremely scared
now there's a lot of theories going
around that this is two-face we can
actually confirm that it's the joker
because of one of the funniest leaks
ever if you cast your mind back to a
couple of months ago you might remember
that barry's brother got drunk one day
and posted a facebook status saying that
he was playing the joker which yeah is
good enough to be one of the clown's
best crimes ever the arkham scene was
reported by several scoopers and matt
reeves did some damage control earlier
in the week saying that the scene had
been deleted this was clearly so that
people could have a surprise and i think
that all these factors confirm that he's
indeed playing the clown prince of crime
it's revealed in the finale that the
riddler actually wanted to work with
batman and that he saw himself as being
the opposite side of the same coin
that's not a two-faced pun but clearly
he's looking for allies which the joker
could bring barry also dropped several
lines about clowns and i think it's
pretty clear who he is when you do the
work of the world's greatest spoiler
detective these two references and
you're actually going to be in the
batman too that's which is why
we can't talk about that you can't talk
about the batman
now this seems to set up a sequel that
could potentially be based on the war of
jokes and riddles or no man's land both
of which turned gotham into a war zone
leading up to no man's land we had the
book cataclysm in which there was an
earthquake that rocked gotham and it
basically turned the city into the big
apple during the john carpenter classic
escape from new york however
interestingly reeves has said that he'd
actually like to bring mr freeze into a
future film hot of ice was such a cool
episode in the animated series and with
reeves behind it it would do just ice to
a character that was transformed into a
joke during batman and robin now we also
know that in hbo max series centered
around the gcpd is coming soon and that
it will be a continuation of this movie
if you've read the gotham central
graphic novels then you'll know that
this series followed the police as they
tackled super villains it very much
showed how the criminals and batman
operate from their point of view and
there was a major run in it that
featured mr freeze let's
kick some ice
i could actually see this being brought
into the series and that it would set
the events for a sequel which would be
one big ice capade thank you thank you
i'm here all week it's also going to be
a penguin series involving the iceberg
lounge owner that will pop up at the
pick up a penguin right where this left
off now the movie also has somewhat of a
post-credits scene in which the code
goodbye pops up and then we get a link
to a website which if you've been
following the marketing is full of
riddles i love how they use php language
and that tends to have a lot of question
marks in it which is of course also a
symbol of the riddler lots of secrets
have been unearthed on this and it's
likely that the clues about the sequel
will show up there too it's just the tip
of the iceberg and hold on to your butts
because the puns are just getting
started i'm kidding i'll try cool off on
them now the film itself is a yeti story
that pulls from several graphic novels
the most notable of these is the long
halloween which as you can probably
guess has a major event on halloween
like the riddler's first murder
throughout it we followed batman as he
investigated several attacks carried out
on the mob that happened every holiday
these all revolved around the mob boss
carmine falcone and his immediate family
allies and mob rivals batman slowly
investigated clues left behind by a
mysterious killer called holliday who
was revealed to be falcone son alberto
who sadly doesn't make an appearance
however the graphic novel completely
reinvented the calendar man and painted
him out as a hannibal lectoresque
villain who helped batman from his
selenarchum the silence of the lambs
clearly influenced this movie and there
are several shots in it that massively
inspired once in this film this graphic
novel had a spin-off book called
catwoman when in rome in which she left
gotham and traveled to europe to confirm
whether her father was carmine or not
eventually this was revealed to be true
however in the movie she already knows
it whereas he doesn't no other notable
graphic novels that inspired the work of
batman earth 1 which this film takes a
lot from in the second volume we watched
as the riddler terrorized the city by
planning explosives through it and this
jigsaw-esque incarnation also clearly
inspires a lot of this movie earth one
saw a far more grizzled alfred than we'd
ever seen before who also likely
influenced andy circus's portrayal there
was also batman punching gordon him
saying he's vengeance and thomas wayne
running for mayor which is a major
subplot in this movie more loosely based
ones are batmania 100 which was a very
diy type of batman of the future used
his mechanic skills to build motorbikes
and he very much tried to appear as a
creature of the night the guy even wore
fake vampire teeth to scare his enemies
and it's a book i definitely recommend
you pick up at one point we see batman
injecting a green substance into himself
and this may be a note of the graphic
novel venom in which he became addicted
to steroids after failing to save a
young girl he managed to beat this need
but the substance later returned down
the line with bane using it to give
himself super strength also this venom
isn't to be confused with venom from the
marvel universe which spawned the
greatest song ever
vanillin
on madonna venom the hush also gets a
nod and this involved bruce's childhood
friend tommy elliot attempting to
torment the character this comes in the
form of a journalist with the same
surname who has the word hush appear in
one of the reports about them now in the
book the riddle rack she went to
tomyalia with batman's identity after he
figured out who was behind the cowl
realizing that riddler everyone knows
the answer to is useless he decided to
keep it to himself which will likely be
what happens in a future movie how am i
part of this
oh you're really not as smart as i
thought you were
bruce
wayne
there's also batman zero yeah vol 2
title dark city in that the riddler held
gotham hostage and though the movie is
based heavily on a lot of comics it also
pulls from real life crimes too now the
riddler costume is highly based on
sketches of the zodiac and what he used
to wear when he killed people there's
also the color explosive that's placed
on gil coulson's neck which pulls from a
real-life bank robbery heist documented
an evil genius you can check out that
story on netflix to see where reeves got
a lot of his inspiration from there's
also movies that he gave notes to such
as seven in chinatown but the film has a
lot of detective noir elements such as
journals and narration the latter of
which was used heavily in the dark
knight return so we could hear bruce's
inner thoughts and reeves clearly pulled
from every aspect of batman that he
could find to flesh out the character
this extends to catwoman 2 who lives
with a woman she protects much like
holly robinson and batmania 1. she might
even be in a relationship with her and
as of now we don't know if she likes
dick grayson as he isn't in the movie
[Laughter]
now the movie itself leans heavily into
the long halloween and its sequel dark
victory as we watch a mass criminal kill
several high-ranking citizens the
riddler is a true mystery enigma though
he is called edward nashon in the movie
instead of his typical comic book name
however we do learn he was an orphan and
i think going forward they might reveal
his true identity as being that in the
sequel either way the guy is a complete
psychopath that probably doesn't hit the
thumbs up on and slowly batman and
selena kyle start to unearth the web of
corruption that's connected to falcone
the investigation goes high and low and
it's all in search of an informant
called el rata a lot of which are
probably messed up and this also just
happens to be the viral website address
that we talked about in the post credit
scene section so definitely go check
that out if you want some more clues on
what's going to be happening in the
future we learned that the rat was
falcone who flipped on salmaroni in
order to basically become the king of
gotham you might know the name maroney
from the source material as he was the
person who threw acid in harvey dense
face it looked high and low for this rat
and this eventually leads batman and
gordon to the ruins of an orphanage
which is similar to how earth one
climaxed we discovered that this was run
by thomas and martha wayne and that it's
where edward grew up called the renewal
project the waynes tried to help
orphanages in the area but after their
death falcone helped us skim the money
into the pockets of the corrupt people
in gotham it was basically turned into a
money laundering business and things
were bleak for the kids that it was
supposed to help
am i part of it
you'll see
we learned that the buildings got so
cold that babies would die in the winter
and ashton discovered all this whilst he
was working as a forensic accountant for
the renewal project riddler said he was
spurred on to get revenge when he saw
the batman fighting crime in gotham and
thus bruce is sort of responsible for
him after sending an explosive to bruce
that alfred opens the villain then leaks
evidence that thomas hired falcone to
kill a journalist whilst he was running
for may this is because they threatened
to reveal martha's history of mental
illness which is a facet of the wanes
that has been explored in the comics as
a tribute to butthead bob kane martha
was originally given the surname martha
kane but this was changed to arkham and
as we learn madness runs in the family
bruce devastated by this reveal then
confronts alfred who confirms that
thomas did indeed ask falcone to
intimidate the journalist they have a
brilliant scene with falcone where he
talks about the night thomas saved his
life that's ripped right out of the long
halloween falcon was taken to thomas
after being critically injured and
batman sat at the top of the stairs
watching him being operated on now we
discovered that after learning falcone
killed the journalist sir thomas decided
to go to the police and no we don't get
it confirmed there are suspicions that
coal mine killed the wanes falcon is
revealed to be the informant and after
we learn he killed selena's friend she
goes off to murder him for all the pain
he's caused in her life batman and
gordon go to the iceberg lounge to stop
her and after leading him outside into
the light ridley shoots falcone from his
apartment this of course leaves a
massive power vacuum in gotham and it's
likely that the penguin hbo max show
will follow cobblepot as he takes over
the criminal empire riddler is then
arrested and we catch him in a cafe that
resembles the painting nighthawks by
edward hopper locked in arkham asylum he
tells batman he wanted to partner with
him and then reveals his true plan which
is that he's hidden 250 riddler trophies
throughout the city
[Music]
just kidding no along the sea wall he's
placed several explosives and when these
detonate they destroy the reservoir and
flood the city this is somewhat taken
from the man who laughs in which joker
wanted to poison the city reservoir
though batman stopped him now we learned
that the riddler basically used 4chan
boards to build a massive following and
that they have plans to assassinate
bella real the mayor-elect of gotham
this leads to a big finale and alongside
selena carl batman manages to put an end
to them however it's very bittersweet
and as we mentioned earlier this will
likely set up a no man's land situation
where the entire city is abandoned by
the government and left to fend for
itself though this was slightly touched
upon in the dark knight rises here they
can really rip things open and have an
all-out war where the criminals and
supervillains buy for power zero yeah
also had the streets of gotham transform
into a savage wasteland which had the
riddler at the helm throughout both
batman pretty much dropped the bruce
wayne playboy persona which robert
pattinson's version hasn't developed yet
so i think they would make sense to be
the next storylines i think that he will
adopt it eventually but in the likes of
both earth one and zero yeah it was
alfred that convinced him that he needed
a face he could show to the people bruce
wayne has connections that batman
doesn't and he's gonna need every
possible avenue he has at his disposal
to stop the joker if he does end up
working with the riddler they have a lot
of interesting ways that they can take
things and i'm very curious to see where
they go next with it now as for selena
she very much says that the city is
beyond saving and decides to leave a
bloodhaven bloodhaven is actually a
neighboring city to gotham that the
likes of nightwing ended up being a
defender of rare rumors that zoe kravitz
will be getting her own hbo max show too
and with the way that the movie leaves
things off i definitely think there's a
strong possibility of it we could also
have the gcpd show basically showing
from the police point of view what's
going to happen with those in the city
now that major areas of it are flooded
it has been confirmed that the penguin
show is closer to shooting but that
could end up being more of a book of
boba fett type series where we get a lot
of flashbacks which hey can't wait to go
back to that hey maybe they'll put him
in a nice pool or something and i
thought my jokes were bad
now as with my thoughts on the movie i
have to say i was completely blown away
by it and not only did it meet my
expectations but it surpassed them in
every single way a lot of the chatter
around this movie will be is it better
than the dark knight which still to this
day remains as the benchmark for dc
movies i think having just come out of
it that i'm gonna have a lot of recency
bias because i've just seen it and when
you're this hyped you can be like best
movie ever made best movie of all time
so i don't want to let that cloud my
judgment i'm going to let it marinate
for a bit but my initial thoughts are
that the dark knight works better as a
movie for general audiences because it's
got a lot of great action scenes some
good humor and you know it's just sort
of a blockbuster movie now whilst this
has those elements too it feels like a
film rather than simply being a popcorn
flick reeves has worn his influences on
his sleeves when talking about this and
even niche films like conversation get a
nod with the opening scenes being very
similar to that movie i don't know which
of the two are preferred but yet that
should let you know how highly i think
of the batman this is absolutely
brilliant and for me it takes a lot of
the boxes in terms of telling a story
that's not only faithful to the comics
but also unique in what it does for this
version batman is someone who's such a
flexible character and one year you can
do batman v superman and the next the
lego batman movie without it feeling
like either or untrue to who he is
greaves has done an incredible job of
putting his own stamp on the character
and along with this is the phenomenal
cast there's pattinson who bats it out
of the park zoe kravitz who might be the
best selena kyle ever colin farrell in
an unrecognizable transformation and
jeffrey wright who brings the gritty and
granite betrayal that you'd expect
everyone does an incredible job and
though i have nitpicks over the film
including its narration heavy third act
i feel they did a phenomenal job
especially for a first attempt this
movie has me so hyped for what's to come
and i really hope that dc learn lessons
from this in joker and decide to
greenlight more directly driven takes on
characters that aren't crippled by
continuity outstanding job and i think
that this movie is a masterpiece where
we go next i don't know but for this
film i'm gonna give it a 10 out of 10.
you
are justice
[Music]
please do not lie
what is the price for your
blind bag
[Music]
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the movie if you agree and if you
enjoyed the video then don't forget to
subscribe right now we have a breakdown
discussing why we love the dark knight
so much and i'd love to see you over
there right after this if not then
thanks for singing until the end of the
video really appreciate it and i hope to
see on the next one take care peace